les protestations au liban restent
quotidiennes depuis maintenant de
nombreuses semaines une grève générale a
également été a décrété aujourd'hui
contre la crise économique qui sévit
partout dans le pays
tous les commerces et magasins étaient
fermés aujourd'hui et sans les rues
vides et silencieuses
on a pu voir également les routes s'est
dégradé à pas des déchets en feu devant
le tribunal du syndicat général la foule
libanaise s'est fait entendre écouter le
pays doit être sauvée des griffes de ces
personnes
c'est là toute la question nous
n'appelons pas bloquer les routes
nous sommes pacifiques et civilisés
notre objectif n'est pas de faire grève
mais notre objectif est de diriger les
choses et pour en train de faire mettre
à deux conférences en droit
international et avocat au barreau de
beyrouth et paris la situation au liban
est alarmante pour lui la communauté
internationale doit agir au plus vite
la communauté internationale doit avoir
un plan d'action afin de libérer le
peuple libanais de tous les problèmes
qui sont là à l'heure est la corruption
sur le plan économique le forez est codé
sérieux transparent reste la voix
appelant immédiatement effectivement
afin de récupérer l'argent du peuple
libanais et dans le secteur privé et
dans le secteur public
sinon ce sont des communiqués politiques
sans merci sens sans résultat quelconque
et au et le peuple libanais va rester
dans le périple et ça va être de plus en
plus dangereux est de plus en plus
pénible pour le peuple libanais et les
époux les générations à venir si la
communauté internationale et la france
en premier ne prennent pas des mesures
coercitives et mesures d'action pour
former un gouvernement un gouvernement
indépendant